بعد اسابيع من المفاوضات الصعبه توصل
الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب والبيت الابيض
الى اتفاق مبدئي لرفع سقف الدين بعدما قدم
الطرفان تنازلات رئيس مجلس النواب كيف
بنقارتي قال ان الشعب الامريكي يستحق
الاتفاق المبدئي واضاف ان خمسه وتسعين في
المئه من الجمهوريين في المجلس متحمسون له
اعتقد ان هذه الاتفاقيه تؤطر كل ذلك من
الحد والمدخرات والنمو وهي لا تعطي الجميع
كل ما يريده لكن هذا هو الحال في حكومه
منقسمه البيت الابيض من جهته رحب بالاتفاق
ووصفه بانه خطوه مهمه الى الامام واعتبره
توافقيا ما يعني عدم حصول الجميع على ما
يريدونه لكنه اضاف انه يحافظ على اهم
اولويات الديمقراطيين
لقد قدم الرئيس بايدن نتيجه تتجنب تعثرا
كارثيا يمنعنا من الانهيار الاقتصادي
ويوقف الجمهوريين المتطرفين من الماجا من
التسبب في ركود يؤدي الى قتل الوظائف وهو
ما رايناه خلال الاسبوع او الاسبوعين
الماضيين بعض ما جاء في الاتفاق رفع سقف
الدين لمده عامين وتقليص الانفاق خلال
الفتره نفسها الابقاء على مستوى الانفاق
غير الدفاعي عند مستوى العام الحالي لعام
اخر
استرداد الاموال التي خصصت لمكافحه جائحه
كورونا ولم
تجديد شروط العمل للحصول على الدعم
الحكومي تخفيض تمويل دائره الايرادات
الداخليه عدم فرط ضرائب جديده
التحدي امام بايدن كارت الان هو اقناع
اعضاء في حزبيهما في الكونجرس بالتصويت
على المشروع حيث يعترض مشرعون جمهوريون
يمينيون وديمقراطيون يساريون على ما
يعتبرونه تنازلات في الاتفاق يتوقع ان
يصوت مجلس النواب على مشروع القانون
الاربعاء القادم قبل ان يتجه الى مجلس
الشيوخ لكن قد يتم ارجاء ذلك اذا واجه
معارضه قويه من الحزبين حسين الطوض
العربيه واشنطن لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات